Представьте, что Python можно учить
не как учебник,
а как настоящую игру,
где каждый новый навык — новый уровень.
Сегодня у новичка есть тысячи видео,
курсов и роликов по программированию.
Ты смотришь теорию,
копируешь код, запускаешь его —
и получаешь ошибку.
И просто не понимаешь,
что делать дальше.
PyQuest создан для школьников
и начинающих программистов.
В PyQuest обучение
превращается в квест.
Ты проходишь визуальные уроки
и пишешь настоящий Python прямо в браузере.
Запускаешь код,
проходишь тесты
и по шагам видишь, как выполняется программа
и меняются переменные.
А если ты застрял,
подключается AI-ментор.
Он не просто выдаёт готовый ответ —
он даёт подсказку и направление,
помогая самому прийти
к правильному решению.
За прогресс ты каждый раз
получаешь XP и монеты.
Открываешь достижения,
выполняешь ежедневные квесты,
проходишь мини-игры, сражаешься с боссами
и соревнуешься с другими игроками.
И самое главное: это уже не идея на слайде,
а прототип, который мы создали.
Python выполняется прямо в браузере
через Pyodide.
Firebase. Gemini API.
Realtime-механики через Socket.IO.
Моя цель — чтобы первый опыт человека
с программированием вызывал не:
«Это слишком сложно»,
а: «Я хочу пройти
следующий уровень».
PyQuest.
Освой Python, играя.